[Applause]
is
is Boycott Israel has become a rallying
cry in protests around the
[Music]
world while we're providing support for
the people of Palestine from here at the
same time we want our own government to
cut off its
support all over the world millions
millions and millions are coming
out and saying no no stop it we will
boycott and isolate Israel until it
hurts
them Israel's war on Gaza has thrust the
BDS movement back into the spotlight
established in 2005 it calls for a
boycott of Israeli and international
companies involved in Israel's
violations of Palestinian rights it not
only provides a list of products to
[Music]
avoid but people are also downloading
apps to check if some businesses support
Israeli products there is a global
effort by Israel to suppress activism
and support for the boycott investment
and sanctions campaign including through
bringing in legislation to try to
suppress such activism and currently one
of the things we're having to do in the
UK is fight an anti-boycott law um that
is specifically aimed at public bodies
like local government pension schemes
and seeks to stop them taking divestment
action so at the moment we have a huge
battle but I think that speaks to the
concerns that Israel holds and that the
government holds about the uh potential
momentum uh in these
campaigns that anti-boycott bill which
is making its way through the British
Parliament says such boycotts or
divestments by public bodies would
potentially be liable to investigation
and fines under the legislation Israel
has long accused the movement of
anti-Semitism but many are making moves
to hit companies where it hurts last
month the Turkish Parliament banned
neslay and Coca-Cola products from its
restaurants and McDonald's has been
under attack after its Israeli franchise
offered free meals to soldiers and some
took it
further
McDonald's corporate office says sales
in Egypt have fallen by at least 70%
since the war started it has pledged
$650,000 in Aid to Gaza and there's a
storm brewing in Starbucks in the US the
coffee franchise has been targeted after
it sued its labor union for a social
media post supporting Palestinians the
union has since counters
sued renewed attention on BDS comes as
Pro ters demand a permanent ceasefire in
Gaza hoping that companies feeling the
pinch will apply pressure on political
leaders to end Israel's war on Gaza
Laura Khan aljazera